hey I'm LP I'm out here I guess I'm out
here trying to promote my ass um I got a
record dropping and in May and I just
came out here to do some shows and hang
out basically a good friend of mine Nick
diamonds from islands it is on the
record and a much more sort of upfront
way and killer Mike and Danny Brown and
exquire death spot imeem it's they're
all just friends of mine really good
friend of mine did did co-production on
some of the songs my boy little shalimar
who has his own you know the thing but
yes these are that's sort of that's what
I do with these records I kind of just
disappear into a hole and try and come
out with you know these these are mine
you know I do a lot of production for
other people but with these records
they're so fully you know me I really
you know that they take a while to do I
just try and say what I'm feeling in the
most concise way and I try and push
myself to kind of do things musically
that I I hadn't quite done yet you know
so hopefully it came out cool you know I
try not to want you know a lot of the
collaborations I do unless they're you
know a lot of them are sort of subtle
you know I described it as being the you
know the
the South Park of the gay dog in South
Park Theory where they got George
Clooney to bark as the gay dog like you
know I I you know with people who are
around me and who i'm who i'm who i like
but I try not to if it doesn't fit I
won't do it and sometimes it's just a
subtle part of the song deaf chicks in
my mind just had run its course in terms
of my involvement and I had done it for
10 years and it was always a labor of
love but I just really felt that I that
um and it was it was difficult and I
wasn't rich and and you know after a
while I just really wanted to focus on
just doing music and um all of the you
know it just felt like it's it was time
you know and I just I'm a big believer
and listening to that voice in your head
you know I'm not you know i know that
i'm not helping anybody if my heart's
not fully in it you know and and it was
always about being fully in it fully
invested in love and being and loving it
and and that's all you know was really
just about about you know feeling like
it was the right time to do something
new Porter rock song come the bad the
castle drive
waters color bra